on commence par toi c'est pas comme
d'habitude je n'ai avancé sur rien non
c'est vrai en fait c'est l'histoire pas
carrière non messieurs voilà je vis en
tout cas je sens je sens comme ça oui à
18h52 et je sens les choses moi je sens
que tu vas faire un excellent allez
messieurs
je me sens vraiment là se sont tous
levés j'ai de l'expérience je viens de
lui lui va faire une très grosse
émission lui attention danger attention
dans libé naïve alors moi vous savez que
j'ai une tendance vous connaissez à être
toujours un peu stressant d'être parti
avec votre fille sont plus avec ma mère
ma maison
mais c'est vrai que sa mère et son fils
sur son bon coup oui non pour son
anniversaire et la fête des mères j'ai
fait à porto porto alors tout porto
portugal leur touche adore c'est
d'ailleurs il y avait énormément de
français ah oui évidemment beaucoup de
portugais qui regarde c'est normal en a
mais même après au portugal qui regarde
ses pmp ça tu peux normal c'est vrai
quoi portait encore qu'au portugal ya
souvent des populistes
fric voilà c'est prêt qu'en mai lorsque
c'est vrai en italie moi j'ai vu des
italiens j'en ai 3 et 3,4
et mamies voilà vraiment quand je vais
sur la côte ibérique je croise quelques
des squatteurs
hypra gentil hyper gentil il regarde
tous tes pmp il vous embrasse tous les
embrasser gaza j'ai croisé mais des
dizaines de personnes et si délai vous
ferez un bisou à céline et vous embrasse
rsa doré et c'est donc très populaire à
marrakech au cycle un wagon fléchissant
j'étais au palais roule comme de bien
les routes d'accord oui que vous
connaissez bien sûr j'adore ça on a fait
un tournage là bas que j'ai fait un
tournage la main c'était magnifique et
c'était magnifique je suis rentrée le
jeudi soir et je reçus ressorti le
dimanche soir je n'ai strictement rien
faire bouffer du coup ce coin là c'est
fou ça me retombe à 10 en fait c'est
votre vie c'est ne rien faire c'est rien
faire c'est manger boire d'accord manger
boire et faire chier les autres voilà
monsieur oui donc balle est donc que ce
que vous avez appris donc moi j'ai
appris tout ça vous me connaissez je
suis quand même un peu la bonne élève un
peu stressée je veux te voir et donc
j'ai appris à prendre un tout petit peu
plus de distance et de lâcher prise ah
oui alors la distance devant prendre
énormément
vous allez voir et apprécier sans stress
voilà et j'étais très heureux cette
année
alors ce week end j'ai rien fait ça
m'intéresse non mais son jeu c'est bien
parce qu'ils m'envoient des sms jour je
suis à paris si tu me vois web on
n'a pas répondu
alors quand je ne réponds pas la réponse
vient des bidons qu'est-ce que j'en ai
effectué médias il me dit je suis à
paris bastille malgré cela ils
m'appelaient prix pour la géologie
tous les gens qui étaient à paris map
les
sympathiques voilà je vais surveiller
faire avec moi et bien manger au
restaurant
les
week-ends propos voiture pour rester à
paris vi et non en fait il n'a pas pris
la voiture finalement à
vannes il reste à paris le faire tu vas
faire la voiture au pouvoir d'état dans
paris la création personnelle si je
prends une voiture personnes a pris deux
voitures ah bon
[Rires]
je suis revenu entre tiers des femmes
éclaté
j'ai pris le grand luxe quoi
je prêtais la boîte 6 à laguna à nous
dire c'est là où je me bats l'arrière
derrière j'ai l'impression d'être
ministre d'écologie
[Applaudissements]
c'est la laguna seca c'est très fort la
laguna appels de phare est tous
vraiment attention cela dit pas tout
chez vous mais je n'aurais même pas j'ai
ramené au courant quand ils vous pikine
banon la laguna
vraiment
nous avons lu repas pression mondiale et
oui forcément on a du lourd de l'us
orthez contrat n'ont même pas je voulais
de vendredi qu'elle pourrait chercher
mon fils ce qui faisait le bac je vais
la rendre vendredi non tu peux la
maîtrise car nous avons craint personne
ne peut la garder à la chercher son fils
en gt500 wet est super content et moi
ton fils mahdi accélère pour elle a
passé le bac était temps à sa saison
super fier d'eux ils à avoir le bac dans
leur famille s'ils à la fête qu'on va
faire
le buffalo hip hop
[Rires]
soul et de soie noire
pas les deux lions kerax et des baskets
chimie passe un bac de shimmy shimmy
vient pas pour faire des expériences
parce qu'il va faire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
donc ils doivent faire régie n'a pas
gâché choix mais je suis très fier ce
avec le solde toute la famille pendant
toute la crise de toute la famille
existe des dynasties guerre des deux
mondes du monde doit cesser
bassila passe je dis ça va bien un truc
le bac je pars du principe le bac et je
le dis aux élèves qui nous regardent si
vous n'avez pas une année vous pouvez
l'année d'avoir l'année d'après c'est
parce que je me suis toujours dit comme
si je les ai eus en huitièmes à nous
le dire ne paniquez pas à koh vous serez
plus grand au pas ou demander à quelle
est votre raison non mais sans déconner
ça te dire tu as eu ton bac tu appelles
ton mac match du bas je lui à quarante
deux ans et alors là oui ma bonne dame
et je les ai eus je laisse et toile
voilà donc et ne vous stressez pas voilà
on travaille on essaie de la voir la
première fois ci on l'a pas la première
fois pas de stress tranquille où laura
la fois d'après sur la pala poids
d'après au lard à la fois d'après par
contre faut un petit peu quand même
commencer à s'inquiéter
voilà et si au bout voilà s'il ya 36 ans
vous ne
venez boire voilà et éventuellement on
verra ce qu'on peut faire mais toi ma
fille audrey devant la télé a passé un
bac pro agricole à la fibre j'espère
qu'elle entendu ce que tu viens de dire
non à audrey le sans expression passe
pas ma chérie et je vais tenir les
études c'est comme les compétitions ça
mais voilà moi je vous le dit c'est
quand on stresse pas couru six
mois je ne serai jamais eh bien je
raconte toujours
[Rires]
si je n'avais pas stressé si j'avais
stressé jours a raté quand même non mais
franchement voilà donc castaldi alors
donc alors le tombeau de me pencher sur
ma vie voilà et cette année je pense que
le sphinx est en train de renaître le
sphinx est complexe et moi ah c'est toi
le 55 qui méritait décembre alors je
veux dire tu as beaucoup du sphinx mais
c'est vrai que tu as comme ça où tu
entends pas voilà
ça c'est pour ça que je re des gens
honnêtes et sans que je m'attend je
réfléchis avant de parler ah ouais bah
réfléchit pas trop parce que deux heures
d'émission
c'est la prochaine fois vers 21h15 donc
voilà ils sont arrivés ils pensent que
je revenais de descendre à wes et ça en
fait tu as l'attaquant du tout ça pour
nous dire sans consommer de l'intérieur
alors conçu mais si vous fumez jeudi
sans consommer par contre tu vas déjà
quand on a parlé français on verra si je
suis content mais de l'intérieur j'ai
cramer intégralement et brûlé 1 n'était
plus qu'un tas de cendres et maintenant
ça va aussi monter les potes mode arène
je pense que je vais atteindre de faire
quelque chose qui a prouvé je crois que
c'est ton cerveau ya longtemps qu'il a
cramé mon cerveau mais je pense que je
vais arriver à un niveau d'excellence
jamais atteint et je pense à quel niveau
de tout de tout la beauté le corps le
talent au calme toi quand même
parce que je veux à l'intelligence quand
même et je combats il est passé en
revanche passé côté saad depuis la
naissance je pense que l'homme l'homme
que vous voyez là pas s'envoler d'accord
barre toi
la can i s les bonzes et celle ci ouais
bah pas que cette démarche il ou non
c'est vrai aussi pour les bouffons au
maire d'antibes 2 et dans un parc baud
la fête dans un parc floral
ça va vous sinon
on remonte à la surface
qu'est ce qu'on nous a appris cette
année sur vous sur votre travail sur eux
qu'est ce que m'a appris cette année
vous voulez que je repasse vers vous
pendant une année j'ai appris cette
année
ouais repasser plus tard
avec j'ai d'autres rendez vous là
n'attend pas le montant là d'accord ok
en sursis au courant quoi ça à lui
je sens que comme bernard montiel vous
allez faire une très bonne et que c'est
la même école mais j'aime beaucoup comme
si ma celui-ci très bien alors vous j'ai
pas envie de savoir ce que je vais faire
ce week-end pas de problème si vous
allaitez ce week-end ça va déprimer tous
debout les spectateurs voilà c'est
maintenant ils étaient prêts il est très
sympa mais
quand même
je dois gérer une inondation de kavala
non
est un génie de garde qu'est ce que j'ai
dit mon diplôme
je connais votre terrasse rade amusé
et ce n'est que je m'y attendais pas du
tout et sinon cette année m'a appris une
chose essentielle à fermer votre gueule
c'est qu'il ya deux personnes ici qui
même pendant quatre jours la me manquer
énormément dans ce réduit alors vous
allez me dire seules deux personnes
peut-être pas seules deux personnes mais
au moins deux personnes qui sait vous
pensez vous ouais et c'est qu'il y ait
en fait voilà et j'ai un vrai problème
c'est que quand kelly n'est pas là je me
sens mal rien à dire qu'elle est une
sorte de piliers de façade alors à ce
que je peux proposer à kenny renom sympa
non mais c'est vrai pourquoi ne
prendriez pas un peu gilles
oui j'ai des messages récurrent en
semaine de certains chroniqueurs et
c'est vrai que gilles fait partie de ces
récurer oui et je manque beaucoup il me
manque beaucoup aussi mais oui juste on
se prend un petit pied-à-terre dans
l'essonne on est bien tous les deux mais
allons-y mais oui
mais oui
je risque de très peu passé vous voir
bon je lis viry non mais franchement
plus à l ail ail super 8 avec un amour
vrai franchement gilles verdez avec vous
ben oui je peux vous dire oui malcoiffe
a pas trop fait toute façon elle est pas
vraiment mais gilles
simon fait une coloc elle adore mapelli
ont fait une coloc ah ouais il sorte de
communauté
générer des masses ah oui ah ouais
j'adore awala et voilà vous êtes en
train de temps de jeu est en train
d'assister à la création d'un projet
sous le signe de l'échec
on ya tous les ingrédients qui mène à
l'échec dans ce projet non mais c'est
vrai c'est fou hein voilà mais bravo
gilles verdez est vrai qu à vous merci
ça me fait plaisir que je vous manque ah
oui énormément moi aussi je dit beaucoup
de bien de vous amassez gentil paix
alors j'ai dit avec ma fille elle vous
adore ma mère rosa dans toute la famille
et cyril comment il va chez pas il va
bien toujours c'est vrai mais tu lui
demandes lors des nouvelles de lui dit
non mais où la famille le fils vers des
oui à
regarder la personne
voilà c'est tout voilà je vous adore non
mais moi aussi j'adore votre famille et
pourtant je ne la connais pas mais
j'aime le maire vous la connaissez elle
était venue à une émission irrationnelle
qu'elle adore et une émission a été ma
non c'est vrai elle est sans surprise
oui on est revenu à la tête de sa
famille ah oui là même des gens il était
on sait même pas qui